hey what's up guys we actually recorded
a pre-roll that went wrong so we're rear
according in here right now we did a
past version of this episode about a
year ago go check out that episode and
Mel you got something to say to our
audience yes so we're getting a lot of
questions asking how can we bring middle
ground to our college campus well fill
out the link in a description box below
the description box below we're gonna
come to your college campus okay enjoy
the episode see you afterwards I didn't
get any boobs what did I do when I
started making money I went and bought
boobs like that's what I wanted you're
gonna die from there implants like I'll
die a d-cup hi my name is Tim I'm a
community organizer here in LA I work on
environmental justice social justice
housing justice and incarcerate state
issues my name is Christian or her I'm
the owner of the seven-figure brand
wealthy college kid I'm 24 years old my
name is Graham I'm a real estate agent
real estate investor and youtuber my
name is Beatrice I am 21 and I am a
target worker my name is Brett Newton I
am an entrepreneur and an investor my
name is tiara lucky and I am a minimum
wage worker I just how slow do instacart
in the muslin actress the first prompt
is I worked for everything I earned
so I grew up with two parents that were
basically paycheck-to-paycheck and none
of them had any extra money it was by
seeing my parents struggle like that
that I really realized the value of
money so I basically poured everything I
had into my work there were years I
would say for years that I didn't have
any friends from 18 to 22 it was just me
and I was working from probably 8 a.m.
until midnight working as a real estate
agent
I completely agree I think that what a
lot of people discount is all the
sacrifices that are made I didn't go to
parties I don't really honestly have
like a ton of friends and it's not like
a sacrifice where I was like I'm gonna
have no friends but you can only balance
so many plates or you drop everything
and the plate that I chose to give up
was a social life there's a lot of
labour and communal effort that goes
into getting all of us here that we
don't get paid for that other people
don't get paid for from the examples
that you two gave are perfect actually
you both are near money by extracting
value from capital transactions you know
you are not building the house you're
selling you're not out there working
like in a slave mind pulling selenium
out of the earth like some people on
this planet are and we have to really
burn money and how we all interact to do
that how would you address this off
extracting value if you start a company
from the ground and then you build it
into a multi-million dollar company but
no one does that because there's
investors and stuff to come in to not
always most of the time I mean you
haven't been kind I've raised I have
raised money before yeah but I've also
started companies I didn't raise money
for how would you find out them by
working a part-time retail job for
minimum wage and then saving up and then
putting it in I have felt judged for my
income level
I think it's part of general society we
are always judging each other having
used snap points before like standing in
a grocery store using the card that I've
gotten to the government to pay for food
and feeling the people behind me
thinking that's something that you
haven't earned or gotten has somebody
ever asked you to use your snap on them
I mean I have generally there's not that
much to go around it's the same
mentality when it's a dollar versus snap
somebody could still ask me to share
well you get it why can't you help me
out I didn't step forward because me
personally I surround myself with people
that just like what's in my bank account
just doesn't matter to the people that
are around me I do think a lot of
judgment towards how much you me
reflects on like your dating experience
that I do feel I've ever had that
because I'm so frugal if there are girls
that are out there who want me for my
money
mm-hmm like they should know I probably
like to cheat this person out there I
literally will wait like 9 p.m. for
happy hour to start just so I get the
happy hour menu
I would be like I would be like the last
person any sort of like gold digger
would want yeah I find myself in
situations with these boys that have no
job no nothing and I end up taking on
these charity cases of relationships oh
why don't you put him on or build him up
I was like you can't build go to bear
I mean you can't I I mean I've met guys
I've dated that you know go on to have
successful businesses from my input you
know you want to date somebody you are
greater but then you don't want to be
materialistic about like well I only
date people with money because I make
money anyone can become rich if you work
hard enough
so I just think that anyone could become
rich if they actually like believed in
themselves and took the risk to actually
believe in themselves that there is some
success at the end of the line of that I
feel like a lot of it comes down to
mindset first and really having the
belief that you can do that I know for
me one of my biggest concerns was I
didn't have any skills whatsoever and I
didn't get into college I have like a
2.0 GPA in high school like it was
terrible I had such bad grades but I
really turned that into a positive and I
really believe this actually happened
for a reason because now I could pursue
something else which was realistic
because that didn't require a college
degree and looking back now that was the
best thing that had ever happened that's
like a really sticky situation with
anyone can become like rich because I
don't think that's completely true a lot
of people can if they have the
connections and stuff you know but feel
like sometimes people like they work two
jobs or sometimes they have other things
going on you have to pay their needs
first
they don't always have like money for
that you know cuz like my dad he's like
that's a poker he has tried making his
own company and it doesn't always think
work out he has tried hard it doesn't
work that's why I think it's like you
have to have connects you know do you
mind if I interject um yeah in in terms
of building connections I didn't have
any connections either when it comes to
you know working in real estate and what
I did to make the connections is they
went to open houses every single Sunday
for months and I probably met at least
50 or 60 real estate agents and it was
through that that I met one agent who
was really gracious enough to say if you
want to come work underneath me I'm
happy to do that and it was really that
connection which you know like you
mentioned connection that I met that
person through just really kind of
putting myself out there to meet people
there's a lot of institutional and
systemic barriers that we aren't really
talking about if you walk into like a
Beverly Hills five million dollar house
not speaking English they're probably
not gonna give you the like hook up we
don't tend to move within circles where
those connections cross economic and
socio-economic lines but even beyond
that I want to say like you took a big
risk and your risk paid off but what if
your risk hadn't paid off and that's for
a lot of people who do try and start
their own businesses try and start their
own YouTube channel that risk doesn't
pay off and there's nobody else aif t
net theirs
we're not really getting an adequate
side of people who like taking that
entrepreneurial risk and not been able
to take it again I'm almost worried it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
though if you go in it fearing oh what
am I gonna fail and that becomes your
main focus I think more people are less
likely to take risks actually needed to
succeed because they're more focused on
not failing if that makes sense yeah I
think your beliefs create the level of
action you take and the level of action
you take determines your results and it
is cyclical I am NOT obligated to give
to the less fortunate so the reason I
stood up on this one is I actually one
of the missions in my organizing is
getting away from this kind of notion
that we have that charity or
philanthropy is the way in which we
solve social problems at the same time
like I still give people money when I
have extra change in my pocket so I
don't want to seem like I'm totally
opposed to I agree with that I've given
people money and not gotten it back I've
given people money and they've wasted it
on drugs why did I even give you the
money to begin with if you weren't gonna
use it to better yourself is it my job
to make sure that you're not going
hungry no we have plenty of you know
organizations that will make sure that
you're eating make sure they have a roof
over your head it doesn't have to fall
on my shoulders for saying I feel like
when you say obligated to give to the
unfortunate it's always the mindset of
like money well guess what I have no
money currently to give but I have like
my morality I have my goodness about me
you know I I'm just trying to build a
community especially when you have a
group of people and that is creative and
supportive you you build faster than
just by yourself i I don't always donate
with money sometimes I'll go and I'll
fill bags of food for kids that are
starving you don't I mean so it doesn't
always have to be money like I don't
think it's our responsibility to give
money based off of what we think the
person's gonna do with it like that's on
them if they choose to use it wrongly
it's our responsibility just to be
generous
I am Not Afraid to spoil myself I
personally do spoil myself I worked hard
to be able to go into a store and get
something for myself but a four thousand
dollar hairless cat that I had
genetically made and when I was in high
school when I started making money I
went and got that cat you know when
you're in middle school and everybody is
hitting puberty and getting taller and
boobs and I didn't get any boobs what
did I do when I started making money I
went and bought boobs that's what I
wanted and you know there's the
controversy of like you're gonna die
from your implants like I'll die a d-cup
and have no problem with it
so I rarely ever treat myself I
basically keep my spending at the same
as when I was like you know 19 or 21 no
matter how much money I make I spend the
exact same amount for instance it sounds
crazy but when I was like 17 I wanted a
Lamborghini and there was nothing I
wanted more I want to be that guy 18
years old and pull up with a Lambo like
that was my dream but when I actually
got the money to go and buy the car all
of a sudden I realized like wait a
second that's stupid I'm not gonna get
the car I'm going to invest it in real
estate instead but then I'm gonna wait
and then I'm gonna get the Lamborghini
and then you save up even more and then
you realize wait the Lambo is still
stupid let me go and you know invest it
and even now like the chase and ambition
of getting something is way more fun and
enjoyable than actually getting that
thing I don't really spoil myself
because I always buy my needs first I
usually wait to like my next check to
see if I have extra money and if I do
then I spoil myself but if I don't then
I just I don't I think it's interesting
also that almost all of us have
associated spoiling ourselves with
spending money and at the same time
spending that money is very unfulfilling
it's weird cuz even myself like I really
just like having an eff off day and I
just hang out and don't do anything and
have any responsibilities but I don't
think about it as spoiling myself even
though that's my favorite time to spare
money for me I think it's always a
comfort thing knowing that I have a
little bit more saved up or invested and
I think it could just be a psychological
thing that no matter how much money I
have it's always psychologically never
going to be enough because that becomes
your new normal so I think you're always
chasing that say I want more money so
that I can pay off like my debt and
travel might help help some family
members and that's it I mean that's why
I mean I want to be like I'll give you
money you know the like I just want it
for my needs you know or just for like a
car because I need a car you know or
just stuff my family needs stuff my
friends need I think for me if I'm
honest with myself it's getting further
away from how broke I was because I'm
scared of that ever happening again
there's no end because of that uh so of
course everyone can always use more
money like I've met billionaires who
could definitely say that they would
want more money but more I want to see
society in which the money that we have
doesn't determine all of our
possibilities because it seems like when
we talk about solving problems it comes
back to money my utopian vision is like
a society where money really doesn't
matter because we don't really need it
to figure out value but it makes a good
translation for the time
thanks so much for watching this episode
of middle ground guys we love having
different people this time around just
to get different perspective exactly if
you guys enjoyed this episode and want
to continue discussion join our Facebook
group in our link below we also have
this super Corsa Grand page so if you
guys aren't falling at this point you're
kind of weird so follow us jubilee media
as always leave a comment below like
subscribe and we'll see you next time